MiMichel C. Auger et Alec
CaCastonguay, bonsoir..
- - bonsoir.
- - Je vous ai vu sourire Alec
CaCastonguay on parlait du
WaWatergate. L'histoire a marqué
l'l'histoire américaine est à
mamarquer l'histoire des mensons
enen politique. Je disais que àa
popose et je sais que je ne
dedevrais pas vous le dire,
c'c'est incroyable qu'on soulige
leles 50 ans du Watergate alors
ququ'on est en pleins mensongese
DoDonald Trump, Enomment
acactuellement et lui
pepense se représenter à la
prprésidence comme si on avait
plplus le même code?
- - C'est clair qu'on n'a même
plplus les mêmes côtes. C'est
dedevenu tellement la chose
dodominant de la politique
amaméricaine. Cela dit, est-ce e
DoDonato va se présenter?
RéRésultant. C'est loin d'être
cecertain. Ce qui est clair,
avavec ce que les républicains
avavaient dans les mains dans le
tetemps de Nixon, ils étaient
prprêts à le destituer.
AuAujourd'hui même après le 7
jajanvier, les républicains sont
totoujours avec 30 et c'est la
prpreuve de la polarisation.
- - Vous suivez ça Alec cette
cocommission du 6 janvier.
CoComment le perçoit avec
plplusieurs entrevues de ses
prproches? Comment il essayait e
sese trouver une voie dans le
memensonge, dans le déni. En
didisant que moi dans par du
pepeuple la constitution je le
memets de côté. Et le problème
bebeaucoup de gens l'ont cru?
- - En 1900 son dos avec Nixon,t
cocomme maintenant c'est la fin
jujustifie les moyens. Tous les
momoyens sont bons. Maintenant
c'c'est prétendre que l'élection
esest volée et on est dans le me
obobjectif ou la partisane Oury
esest plus important que les
ininstitutions.
AÀ l'époque il y avait plus de
gagarde-fous au Parti républica,
bebeaucoup de gens pour qui la
MaMaison-Blanche était importane
etet les instituts est importan.
OnOn était prêt à mettre le
prprésent de pour préserver la
dédémocratie et la c'est
prprobablement moins clai avec e
paparti républicain,
gagarant de ces institutions. Il
n'n'y a plus beaucoup de garde-
fofous à l'intérieur d'un grand
paparti comme le Parti républicn
popour empêcher un président qui
veveut passer par tous les moyes
popour rester au pouvoir.
- - C'est très troublant et vous
avavez raison. Mulroney qui dit:
àà la question est-ce que vous
coconnaissez dans le parti
coconservateur aujourd'hui, vous
alallez voir la diète.
IlIl refuse de voir Poilièvre
gagagnant absolu mais il refusee
didire premier, deuxième troisie
chchoix. Il dit que les bonnes
vivieilles conventions sont-ell.
JeJe vous fais entendre...
- - il aime ça.
- - Il aime ça.
PiPierre Paulus et Gérard Deltel
ququi réagisse.
PIPIERRE PAUL-HUS, député, PCC
ChCharlesbourg-Haute-Saint-Chars
- - Premièrement, le Parti
coconservateur de M. Mulroney
dede l'époque puis le Parti
prprogressiste-conservateur,
c'c'était un autre parti,
unune autre philosophie. Le Pari
coconservateur du Canada, c'est
lele Parti conservateur du Canaa
quque je connais, moi, depuis
quque je suis impliqué en 2008.
PuPuis c'est l'opinion
dede M. Mulroney. Pour moi,
çaça change pas grand-chose.
GEGÉRARD DELTELL, député, PCC,
LoLouis-Saint-Laurent, Québec
- - Le parti est tel qu'il est,
chchaque chef imprime
soson approche, comme M. Mulrony
l'l'a fait et comme d'autres l't
fafait, comme M. Harper l'a fai,
alalors avec des styles
cocomplètement différents.
MaMais ça, c'est normal,
c'c'est l'évolution d'un parti
popolitique.
- - Si Pierre Poilièvre l'empor,
esest-ce que le parti pourra se
reressouder et le chef imprimé e
didirection et QAnon qui restert
dederrière Michel?
- - Il ne faut pas oublier que e
paparti de Monsieur Mulroney est
coconservateur et quand il y a
fufusion avec... c'est le
papartenaire junior de la fusio.
OnOn a plus acheté le nom
coconservateur qu'on a fait de a
plplace aux idées des
prprogressistes conservateurs qi
ététaient un petit parti des de.
C'C'est vrai que c'est notre
épépoque. C'est un parti qui a
dadans le centre de gravité
dédéplacé vers l'ouest, et aussi
vevers la droite plus à droite.t
MoMonsieur Mulroney qui est un
hohomme du centre. Aujourd'hui
didire qu'il est centriste, c'et
prpresque une insulte.
- - Si comme prévu, Pierre
PoPoilièvre l'emporte, qu'est-ce
quque ça veut dire sur l'unité e
cecette partie?
- - Il va y avoir de gros
ququestionnements chez les
mimilitants et ses députés qui e
didisaient qu'il y avait encoren
pepeu d'ADÉEN conservatrice,
prprogressistes conservateurs ds
cece parti.
LaLa course à la direction avec
dedes jouets sérieux comme Patrk
BrBrown, Jean Charest, et que
PiPierre Poilièvre emporte que e
cocourant n'est plus fort pour
gagagner. On n'a pas l'impressin
quque Pierre Poilièvre le fait e
plplace dans le parti et il pase
plplus de temps, dit que les
papartisans de Maxime Bernier qi
foforme le parti soit 345 % dans
leles sondages que d'aller
chchercher des idées du parti
prprogressiste conservateur,
alaller chercher des idées qui
popourraient plaire à Pierre
PoPoilièvre et à Patrick Brown.
- - Qui ne tend pas beaucoup la
mmère Mulroney?
- - Qui ne lui tend pas la maint
seses partisans de Jean-Charlest
PaPatrick B. Est-ce que vont
vovouloir former une partie, ree
àà la maison ou aller voter chez
leles libéraux, qui seraient mos
àà gauche? Il y a des
ququestionnements sur les
mimilitants qui vont se sentit
ororphelin.
- - Avant qu'on analyse des
chchiffres, on les analyse la, n
vovoit Poilièvre... la libre c't
leles conservateurs.
LaLa ligne rouge, c'est tous les
gegens sont des, l'ensemble.
PiPierre Poilièvre est très
popopulaire chez les militants
coconservateurs.
DaDans l'ensemble de la populatn
ilil est beaucoup moins.
JeJean-Charest a le même score t
c'c'est l'ensemble des
coconservateurs. 4 %. Brown està
6 6 %. Avec ces chiffres,
esest-ce que c'est réglé pour
PiPierre Poilièvre?
- - Ce n'est pas réglé mais c'et
bibien Frostad réglé. Le problè,
c'c'est la libre qui compte. Ce
n'n'est pas la route.
PoPour arriver à l'élection
gégénérale il faut devenir chef
d'd'abord. Et même dans les brus
ququ'on entend par rapport aux
dedeux autres, Pierre Poilièvre
esest très en avance. D'ici
seseptembre et peut remonter mas
n'n'y a rien de jouer. Monsieur
PoPoilièvre, il y a un espèce de
momoments Poilièvre dans le pari
coconservateur. On veut cette
drdroite dure plutôt que des
prprogressistes conservateurs,
cocomme Monsieur Charest.
C'C'est vraiment... ça va être
didifficile il va falloir...
ilil va falloir que Poilièvre
peperde de lui-même. Quelle bele
élélection mais ça ne semble pas
vevenir...
- - je vous rappelle à l'école e
c'c'est pas mal?
- - N'est pas fini tant que ce
n'n'est pas fini mais dans le cs
d'd'une avance comme ça, ça va
êêtre difficile à surmonter. Ily
a a un système de pointage
cocomplexe au parti conservateur
ququi fait qu'on attend de voiùu
sosont réparties ces appuis. Es-
cece au Manitoba, SaskatchewanÇa
nene permet pas de remporter au
paparti conservateur mais avant
soson.
PiPierre Poilièvre sera réussi n
memettant la poubelle à la séane
ququi va être mis à la poubelle
sosont des communes. C'est oblié
lélésion du Web : X, Amazon, de
cocontribuer à l'écosystème
cacanadien. Mettre de l'argent
dadans la cagnotte pour qu'on
pupuisse avoir des musiciens
d'd'ici.
IlIl déconnait tout ça de côté.
EsEst-ce une demande unanime de
l'l'assemblée nationale, de
l'l'industrie culturelle qui est
lalarge au Québec?
IlIl faudrait qu'il explique à a
drdroite ou aller chercher des
sisièges au Québec pour faire ue
cacampagne électorale sur la
dédéfensive sans parler des
d'd'autres questions :
crcryptomonnaie la banque du
CaCanada?
LeLes candidats de pied. Les mês
élélus au parti conservateur, ça
vava être intéressant de voir si
leles capables d'être compétiti.
- - Ça c'est le 10 septembre le
chchoix s'il est conservateur.
IlIls vont voter avant ça, faire
lele premier, deuxième, troisièe
etet quatrième choix et en même
tetemps.
N'N'est pas une convention... un
cocongrès, pardon, ou la dynamie
fafait confiance idées.
ToTout ça va être réglé avant.
AlAlec, je reviens sur cette
ththéorie des gens qui disent qe
sisi Poilièvre gagne, comme ça
sesemble être le cas, il y aura
unune scission et aura des gens
ququi auront envie de créer un
auautre parti conservateur plusu
cecentre.
C'C'est peut-être là l'école por
MoMonsieur Poilièvre parce que
mmême si ce parti ne va pas si
loloin, il peut brouiller les
cacartes Michel?
- - Commencer à dire : on va fae
rarapidement. L'élection s'en
vivient et les conservateurs se
didisent beaucoup : "les libérax
onont été à au pouvoir durant ue
didizaine d'années et la démence
vava jouer pour nous." Même s'il
nene trouve pas Pierre Poilièvr,
ilils disent que c'est le tempse
chchanger le gouvernement.
OnOn attend ça chez les partisas
dede Pierre Poilièvre.
IlIl y aura des gens qui
dédécideront de rester à laa
mamaison, des députés de Québecn
paparticuliers qui ne vont pas e
prprésenter. C'est possible.
DiDire qu'on aura le temps de
foformer un parti politique et
totout ça, ce n'est pas évidentt
çaça prend du temps. Maxime
BeBernier...
- - vous êtes d'accord avec Ale?
EsEst-ce plus une vue de l'espr?
- - Il y a un travail de terrain
esest important. Il faut un chef
ququi transcende et qui soit
cacapable avoir un succès
élélectoral. Est-ce que Jean
ChCharheika a le goût lui s'il t
babattu est-ce qu'il a le goût e
sese lancer dans la création d'n
paparti avec toute l'énergie dea
dedemande? Il a été dit à ces dx
paparties était deux? Est-ce qul
a a le goût de revivre ça, faire
lele tour du pays? Il serait trs
bobon, il encore cette vie. Mais
esest-ce qu'il va y arriver.
PaPatrick B. N'est pas
susuffisamment bons en français.
CÇa prendra un gros nom pour y
ararriver. Si ce n'est pas Jean
ChCharest, je ne vois pas la
prproximité de créer ce parti à
cocourt terme.
- - Brown a dit que si Jean
ChCharheika, qu'il part du part.
IlIl y a des gens qui vont partr
avavec eux inévitablement Miche?
- - Des gens partiront mais pas
nénécessairement ailleurs.
IlIls font parti de la maison.
IlIl me reste à la maison et on
veverra ce que ça donne, et on
veverra si ça fait jouer le
prprincipe de l'alternance. Les
lilibéraux aussi dans cette
sisituation et peut-être avec un
momotif un peu plus à droite coe
MoMonsieur Trudeau Sissons Quavs
dede se maintenir. Mais l'on est
dadans la conjecture pure et ona
atattendre de voir.
- - On va temps. Et à l'é'école
ququ'est-ce qu'on va surveiller
d'd'ici le 10 septembre?
AÀ partir de quel moment et
cocommence à voter et qu'est-ce
ququi pourrait arriver et pourrt
chchanger la donne?
- - Il y a tout un travail de
teterrain à faire pour que les
memembres qu'on a recrutés votr.
LeLe processus n'est pas un pitn
susur Internet. Il faut remplirn
papapier, envoyait son permis,
atattendre. Il y a beaucoup de
gegens qui soient faits de voir
leles candidats mais qui ne vont
papas voter.
DaDans une course à la durée dea
momoitié qui ne vaut pas. Sont
momotivés. Les processus les
rerebute, les oublis et c'est en
plplein été penseur de choses.
JeJe savais capable vous fais
sosortir de votre alors que le
prprocessus complexe? Ça va être
asassuré pour mo